let's talk about the best foods to
consume for
reducing a fibroid a fibroid
is a tumor that's growing
on the inside of the uterus and they can
sometimes grow in different parts of the
uterus but
they could be the size of a pea to the
size of a basketball
so the main thing you need to know is
you want to avoid
foods that cause growth
cheese is filled with hormones and you
definitely want to avoid cheese
and that is because milk helps a baby
calf grow into a cow
so milk has all sorts of growth factors
and of course they make cheese out of
milk
now soy is another plant that is very
estrogenic
so you want to stay away from all
versions of soy
you want to stay away from anything that
increases
estrogen and that includes flaxseed
as well now in addition to that you want
to avoid foods that trigger
insulin because insulin is a very
powerful growth hormone
and of course you'd want to go low carb
and low
sugar but here are the foods that have
various phytonutrients that can help
decrease inflammation
decrease fibrosis and decrease
angiogenesis which is the formation of
new blood supply
to a fibroid so number one berries
number two garlic three cauliflower
four tomato five onion
six broccoli sprouts seven
peppermint you can do that in a tea or
blend in with certain foods
number eight shallots which are like
these baby little onions
and then we have peanuts which will give
you some resveratrol
which can also be found in red wine but
the problem with that is the alcohol
um doesn't really help you shrink your
fibroids
and lastly fasting intermittent fasting
and periodic prolonged fasting is
probably
one of the most powerful things you can
do for fibroids so if you combine that
with healthy keto and make sure you have
some of these foods right here
i think that would be a perfect plan
hey before you go real quick i have a
course
entitled how to bulletproof your immune
system
it's a free course i want you to take it
and here's why
here's you here is your
environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here
what about strengthening
your immune system that's what's missing
this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself
and so you can tolerate and resist your
environment much better
by strengthening your own immune system
i put a link down in the description
right down below
check it out and get signed up today